in addition to everything in the present
a theory of everything must also unify
past and future from our beginnings in
the big bang
all the way to the ultimate fate of the
universe
that is a theory of everything explains
not only the rules of matter and energy
in the present
it will also explain the history of the
universe from the beginning to the end
it will give the details of the
primordial fireball an explosion of
space-time and what it looked like as it
expanded and cooled it will describe the
role that the known forces played and
when they emerged from more fundamental
forces
and we necessarily have a lot of
ignorance for parts of the story
i mean there's so much that we don't
know but we also know a lot so i'll tell
you the story both the bits that are
well grounded in known science and the
bits that range a bit more deeply into
the realm of the speculative
to start this story let's first sketch
out the basics
using observations made by edwin hubble
in 1929 we know that the universe is
expanding and thanks to astronomer fred
hoyle we now call it the big bang
according to the popular view of the
theory the universe was once
concentrated into a point with zero
volume what scientists call a
singularity and it exploded
it's probably worth reminding you that
singularities aren't real it means that
you've pushed a theory beyond the realm
over which it applies
so this singularity shouldn't be taken
extremely seriously it's just a
reasonable approximation and we can use
it even though we know it's wrong in
detail
most people have a mental image of the
big bang as a grenade exploding somehow
this image is wrong as it implies that
there's a center to the universe and if
you had some sort of super faster than
light drive that you could travel to the
spot and stand on the location where the
grenade went off so to speak
however this vision is very misleading
there are questions of what came before
the big bang and what exists outside our
universe but in this lecture i want to
talk exclusively about our universe
to do that i'd like to first sketch out
the big ideas of our universe as it
currently is
then talk about how we think the
universe might have looked at the
incident of creation
and then use the physics that we've
learned thus far to unify the origin of
our universe with the universe that we
know today
so what do we know about the universe
now
it was born in a primordial fireball
about 14 billion years ago
if we look to the cosmos in any
direction we find that galaxies are
generally moving away from us and the
farther away they are the faster way
they move galaxies within 10-ish million
light years are moving toward us or with
us but galaxies far away are moving away
from us with a certain velocity
galaxies twice as far away are moving at
double the velocity
triple the distance and you get triple
the velocity and so on
this recessional velocity doesn't depend
on the direction you're looking
look in that direction
and you get one relationship between
distance and the velocity at which
galaxies move away from us and if you
look in that direction you see the same
thing
and it's the same everywhere in the
universe it's not like a blast site
where some locations are closer than
others
every place in the universe sees distant
galaxies moving away in all directions
there's another bit of evidence that we
must take into account
in 1964 american physicist arno ponzias
and robert wilson discovered a hiss in
the radio wave spectrum that was
identified to be nothing less than the
signature of the fireball of the big
bang
this might be a little hard to get your
head around especially if you're
thinking of a fireball as a big glowing
orangish kind of thing
but if you think about an explosion in
slow motion it starts out white hot then
as it expands the temperature drops and
the color turns yellow and an orange and
then red and finally it cools to the
point where it can't be seen
however there are parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum that also can't
be seen in visible colors if you will
in the same way while the temperatures
of the big bang were once unfathomably
high emitting gamma waves from sources
far hotter than create visible light the
universe has since expanded and cooled
in fact the temperature of the universe
the temperature of the big bang
has now cooled all the way down to 2.7
kelvin or 455 degrees below zero
fahrenheit
and an object with that temperature will
emit radio waves which is what penzias
and wilson observed
the wavelength of these radio waves is
about two millimeters which is on the
short end of the radio spectrum and
overlaps with the microwave range
for this reason this radio hiss is
called the cosmic microwave background
or cmb
there is one interesting feature of the
cmb it's very uniform
this uniformity is very puzzling and for
a very interesting reason
the cmb that we see coming from that
direction was emitted essentially when
the universe began and it's now just
getting to us and the same is true for
the cmb coming from that direction
and that's a bit of a mystery because
the light from one side of the universe
hasn't made it to the other side
so in principle the two sides of the
universe were never in contact
the only way you'd expect to see that
sort of uniformity was if all the points
of the universe were once in the same
place at the same time
our best explanation for this is a rapid
period of cosmic inflation shortly after
the big bang
there is one more curiosity about the
cmb
while it's very uniform in 1998
scientists observed that it had tiny
variations about one part and a hundred
thousand
if you make a picture that accentuates
the variation you see that the sky is
splotchy
this also needs an explanation and we
have an answer for that as well and it
might be the coolest explanation of all
as it ties together the smallest
imaginable phenomena with something as
big as the entire visible universe
the uniformity of the cmb is but one
aspect of the universe that is hard to
explain without a theory of everything
there are two others that are quite
perplexing
the first is the amazing uniformity and
the distribution of matter throughout
the universe
now i have to be careful here i mean we
see tons of evidence that what i just
said isn't true
just look into space there are places
where there are planets and stars and
places where there is well empty space
so even in our solar system we don't see
matter distributed uniformly
but if we look at a galaxy things look a
bit more uniform although in the case of
the milky way there are spiral arms and
gaps in between looking from even
further distances the idea of uniformity
seems silly again as there are galaxies
separated by huge distance of space
looking at further distances still we
see that galaxies are located among huge
ribbons and sheets winding their way
through space separated by huge voids
in which nearly nothing can be found
except dark energy
however when we look at the visible
universe as a whole
taken in all of creation we see that all
of those smaller clumpy structures are
just small potatoes and that the matter
of the cosmos is amazingly smoothly
distributed
that's just an extraordinary observation
and it really needs explaining
however perhaps the most perplexing
feature of the universe is why space
itself has the shape it does
even talking about the shape of space is
hard for most people to get their heads
around for instance
space could be flat like a table
space could be curved like the surface
of a sphere or a donut
space could be shaped like the surface
of a horse saddle
space could be undulating like
sinusoidal waves or it could be in any
manner of distorted configurations
remember that one of the consequences of
einstein's theory of general relativity
is that space and time can be distorted
the mathematical possibilities are
literally endless
but space isn't all of those
possibilities in fact to the best of our
ability to measure it space is flat
perfectly mathematically flat
we've been able to determine this by
looking at those variations of
temperatures in the cosmic microwave
background radiation
we understand pretty much how they came
to be and we know how far away they are
because we know how old the universe is
if space is distorted it would distort
the patterns we see in those hot spots
yet when we look at them they appear
exactly as we would expect if space was
perfectly flat on the largest scales
yes there are local deformations due to
clusters of galaxies and local
variations of matter but when you ask
the question of the overall structure of
the universe it's flat
and that's just weird i mean of all the
possible configurations flat is just one
of them it is also somehow special
why the special one
so those handful of things are puzzling
the uniform expansion of the universe
the uniformity of the remnants of the
primordial fireball the uniform
distribution of matter in the universe
and finally the flatness of space these
are all observations that we will have
to explain with our theory of everything
so what do we know
well the short answer is that we don't
know but we have an idea that could
bring it all together
this idea is called inflation it was
first published in 1980 by american
physicist alan guth
the basic idea is simple and it's just
an extension of the usual idea of the
big bang
in inflation theory the universe began
and it started to expand
remember that the big bang isn't what
happened at time equals zero but it's
everything after time equals zero that's
not central to what i'm talking about
here but i want to repeat it every
opportunity because the misconception is
so deep in our culture
so the big bang began and the universe
was expanding that's not new
what's new is at the time early in the
process the universe began to expand
exponentially
the details are not known but the
scientists believe that about 10 to the
minus 34 seconds after the big bang is a
reasonable starting point
then for something like every 10 to the
minus 34 seconds the size of the
universe doubled and this process went
on until just shy of 10 to the minus 32
seconds
so the total duration was very short but
in that period there were 100 doubling
periods
and 2 raised to the 100th power is about
10 to the 30th power which is an awfully
big number
during that time the universe expanded
from a size far smaller than a proton to
the size of a grapefruit or so and with
this one idea booth explained everything
so how did he do that well to begin with
when the universe was super tiny it was
all in contact and thus was homogeneous
the expansion pulled matter apart from
one another and the subsequent normal
expansion of the big bang kept them
apart never to interact again
but the matter in energy was already
imprinted with the initial homogeneity
so that explains the uniformity of the
cosmic microwave background and the
distribution of matter
now how inflation explains the flatness
of space is even cooler
suppose that before inflation that space
was actually distorted say it had the
shape of a sphere
after inflation no matter what shape it
started out with it would look flat
the easiest way to envision that is to
think what happens if you could take a
marble and scale it up to the size of
the earth
while the earth is no doubt a sphere you
wouldn't know it standing on the plains
of kansas where the planet seems flat
for as far as the eye can see in fact no
matter what the original shape of the
universe was immediately after it began
inflation will always make it appear
flat
there are some consequences of inflation
theory that people find a little curious
for instance you might ask just how fast
the universe expanded if it went from
essentially zero size to the size of a
grapefruit and 10 to the minus 32
seconds
if we take the radius of a grapefruit to
be 10 centimeters that works out to a
speed of 10 to the 31 meters per second
which is much higher than the speed of
light which is 3 times 10 to the 8th
meters per second
if you've been conditioned to think that
nothing can travel faster than light
this might trouble you
however the restriction on objects and
the speed of light deals with objects
traveling through space-time
not the expansion of space itself
in fact in general relativity there's no
restriction on the expansion of space so
this seems like a problem but it isn't
the second consequence is that it means
that the universe is bigger than we can
see
the universe began 13.7 billion years
ago and the most distant light from the
earliest moments is just reaching us
however the universe has been expanding
while that light's been traveling and
the upshot is that the radius of the
visible universe appears to be 13.7
billion light years but at this moment
the diameter is actually about 90
billion light years
however inflation suggests that the
universe is much larger than that
so we need to be careful when we talk
about the universe there is the universe
and the visible universe
while the visible universe has a size we
know
the universe itself could well be
infinite
so what could have caused inflation
well basically you need an energy source
now don't think that the question is
answered because it's not but there's at
least one idea that is interesting
it comes from the concept of a phase
transition
a phase transition is like when water
turns to ice it's when matter or energy
changes form somehow
and in the transition energy is
extracted
for instance it won't surprise you that
energy is coming out of water as it's
cooled however energy is also coming out
of water when it reaches zero degrees
celsius and begins to freeze
and the amount is surprising
as it happens just about as much energy
comes out of water as it cools from the
temperature needed to make tea to zero
celsius as comes out of the water during
freezing
and phase transitions are not a metaphor
they're part of the theory
for instance if there's a grand unified
force that includes both the strong and
electro weak forces when that force
turns into two separate forces that's a
phase transition
in fact the energy that is released
during this transition is one candidate
for inflation
it's not the only candidate but it
certainly would be an incredibly elegant
solution it would combine both the
unification at the smallest size scales
with a very curious observed uniformity
of the cosmos
nice and economical explanations like
that are exactly what we like to see in
a successful theory of everything
okay so understanding the origins of our
universe is a way to try to pull it all
together to connect quarks to the cosmos
so to speak so what do we know
we know of the standard model and we
know of general relativity
we know how matter acts when it's
stationary and how it acts as it
approaches the speed of light
we know how matter works under
temperatures near absolute zero nearly
460 degrees below zero fahrenheit and as
high as 4 trillion degrees celsius
we've explored the universe at size
scales as small as about 10 to the minus
20 meters and to the size of the
universe itself at 10 to the 27 meters
it's now possible to sketch out a
timeline of the universe from beginning
to the present using particle
accelerators we understand the rules of
the universe to energies approaching 10
trillion electron volts which we think
corresponds to times after about 10 to
the minus 13 seconds after the big bang
now you should be very cautious here
before about 10 to the minus 13 seconds
after the big bang we speculate
in fact that earlier realm reflects
times and energies for which we need
better experiments and better theories
those theories could invoke extra
dimensions supersymmetry super strings
loop quantum gravity or something else
that nobody's imagined yet
indeed if we ever want to understand how
the universe came into existence and got
where it is today we absolutely must
figure out a theory of everything
and the arrow goes both ways figure out
a theory of everything and we'll know
how we came to be
so let's start out as do all good
stories at the beginning
as i tell the tale i will distinguish
between what we know and what we imagine
i will further try to highlight points
at which the differing theories we've
learned about so far give us a different
picture of how it all began
i will separate the history into
different epics
during
which different physics play a dominant
role
we begin in the planck epoch in which is
the period of time between 0 and 10 to
the minus 43 seconds
even using the most traditional of
theories ones in which the standard
model and general relativity or the
final word in physics we know that the
very meaning of physics breaks down
before the planck time which is 10 to
the minus 43 seconds
so prior to that time we have absolutely
no idea what's going on nor is there any
prospect of using what we've learned
thus far to project into this era
realistically i think this might be an
impenetrable barrier but we don't
understand the realm well enough to say
anything definitively
however using fairly traditional physics
things clear up a bit after 10 to the
minus 43 seconds
after that time the energy of
interactions is about 10 to the 19th
billion electron volts of energy and the
temperature is 10 to the 31 degrees
celsius
it's at this point in the history of the
universe that gravity is thought to
break off from the other known forces
this is the natural time of a theory of
everything it's the period of super
strings if that happens to be the right
idea or it's the period where loop
quantum gravity comes into play and if
loop quantum gravity is real that
particular theory postulates an earlier
universe before the big bang the details
of that early universe are extremely
speculative but the idea is an exciting
prospect for those who found the idea of
a single creation event to be
unsatisfying
if the idea of extra dimensions as an
explanation for the weakness of gravity
turns out to be right then the times and
energies i've mentioned here are not
right
dude if if inflation is real times and
energies again would be different
the big idea of gravity splitting off
from the other forces is probably right
in any of these cases but don't take any
of this specific numbers too seriously
the grand unified epoch exists from
about 10 to the minus 43 seconds to
about 10 to the minus 35 or 10 to the
minus 34 seconds or so
during this period the strong weak and
electromagnetic forces were all unified
into a single grand unified force
the nature of this force is not yet
known
the temperatures at the end of this
epoch were about 10 to the 26 degrees
and the characteristic energy was about
10 to the 15 billion electron volts
if inflation is a correct idea it is the
period from about 10 to the minus 34 to
10 to the minus 32 seconds give or take
that inflation occurred
during this period the universe was
experiencing a hyperkinetic period of
expansion which flattened space and
forever erased any possible complexity
of the earlier universe
in some respects inflation is nearly as
much of barrier to understanding earlier
times as the start of the universe
itself
of course we're not certain that
inflation really happened if it didn't
then we'll need another explanation for
the uniformity of the universe
which means that our understanding of
this period is murky indeed
from the time period of about 10 to the
-32 seconds until about the minus 12
seconds we don't know the details of
what's going on
at 10 to the minus 12 seconds the
characteristic energy is about a
thousand billion electron volts and the
temperature is about 10 to the 15
degrees celsius
this is the realm where we've taken data
using particle accelerators and we
therefore understand what's going on
pretty well
you'll notice i didn't talk about
supersymmetry and where it comes in
that's for a couple reasons first we
don't know if supersymmetry is something
that exists in our universe
the second is that even if it does until
we've discovered it and found the energy
at which supersymmetry is broken we
can't assign an energy and temperature
for which it occurs
similarly even though we've discovered
and confirmed all the antimatter
particles the observed asymmetry between
matter and antimatter occurs somewhere
in there
if no new physics exists between the
realm where we're currently exploring
and the grand unification scale the
energy regime from 100 billion to 10 to
the 15 billion electron volts is called
the desert which simply means there's
nothing new to be discovered for a very
long time
it's kind of like explorers of space
they can zoom around the solar system
encountering planets and asteroids as
they move into the outer solar system
things get harder and harder to discover
as they're separated by bigger and
bigger distance
however once a spaceship breaks free of
the world of planets and even the earth
cloud of comets it encounters empty
interstellar space
and there's an awful long distance
between the outskirts of our solar
system and the neighborhood of the next
star
if the desert seems frustrating to you
imagine how frustrating it is to me
this is the realm where my colleagues
and i labor looking for dark matter and
supersymmetry leptoquarks and prions
as we dig through our data we
desperately hope that we'll encounter a
surprise like the american americas were
to columbus or keeping with the desert
metaphor we hope that we will at least
find an oasis or two along the way
at a minimum we'd like to rest in oasis
where the antimatter asymmetry is
explained
as times get later and later we
understand far better what happened as
the universe was born
that's a consequence of years and
decades of research
at 10 to the minus 12 seconds the
electro weak force splits into the
familiar weak and electromagnetic forces
the higgs field has come into existence
and subatomic particles of mass
the universe is very hot so matter and
antimatter particles are still appearing
and disappearing
the universe is dominated by radiation
as it's hot enough that the particles
that existed at that time are constantly
radiating energy
this is also the time period during
which the universe was hot enough to
allow quarks to exist without being
bound up inside baryons and mesons
indeed quarks and gluons can run around
willy-nilly in a state of affairs called
a quark gluon plasma
for this reason we call this period the
quark epoch
you could think of this as the time when
protons and neutrons are melted except
that protons and neutrons had not been
formed at all yet
which brings us to the next epoch
at a time of about 10 to the minus 6
seconds the universe had cooled some
more
the characteristic energy was about a
billion electron volts this is the realm
where quantum chromodynamics comes into
play and starts binding quarks into
protons and neutrons for the first time
at temperatures just above a trillion
degrees centigrade the last important
building blocks of atoms came into
existence joining the electrons that we
think existed from the very beginning
from the period about 10 to the minus 6
seconds until 100 seconds after the
universe began is what we might call the
hadron era in which quarks combine to
form hadrons both baryons and mesons
protons neutrons electrons photons and
neutrinos scurried around the universe
as it expanded and cooled as did other
unstable baryons and mesons that
scientists discovered in the 1950s
time could be now measured in minutes as
about three minutes after the big bang
the characteristic energy was about a
million electron volts and the
temperature was about 10 trillion
degrees
the universe had finally cooled enough
so that protons and neutrons could
combine and form the nuclei of light
elements like deuterium and helium
heavier elements like carbon and oxygen
and the rest of the periodic table would
have to wait until they could be forged
in the furnaces of stars that were yet
to be born
from the period of three minutes to 380
000 years after the universe began it
was too hot for atomic matter to form
but just shy of 400 000 years after our
story started the universe had cooled to
about 3000 degrees centigrade and the
energy had dropped to about a single
electron volt
this allowed the first atoms to be
formed
finally matter was cool enough that
electrons and protons could combine to
make hydrogen and alpha particles and
electrons could combine to make helium
this was the period at which the
universe became transparent
with all of the electrons bound to
atomic nuclei the photons that had been
keeping the universe hot suddenly didn't
have anything to interact with so they
could march across the cosmos forever
this was the moment in which the cosmic
microwave background radiation became
visible and when we see it today we're
seeing the universe like it existed 380
000 years after the universe began
although the light has been converted to
microwaves by the expansion of the
universe
and remember when we talked about the
little variations in the cmb where it
had spots that were hotter and colder
the current explanation for those spots
is that when the universe just began it
was filled with quantum foam which are
short-lived and evanescent virtual
particles
if the idea of inflation is true then we
can explain the spots
they are those little variations in
energy density of the quantum foam
frozen in time and expanded by inflation
to span the cosmos
and that is just about the coolest idea
ever
the idea that phenomena so small that
we'll never be able to image them
directly can create structures that are
hundreds of millions of light years
across there is no other example of the
cosmic and the quantum so
intertwined after 380 000 years the
particle physics component of the
universe muted and gravity took over
at this point the currently visible
universe is just shy of 100 million
light years across
while expansion from the big bang
continues over the millions and indeed
billions of years gravity's inexorable
tug pulls diffuse clouds of hydrogen
into dense knots that eventually ignite
with a fire of nuclear fusion
stars form and burn and die in glorious
explosions called supernovae in which
the seeds of planets and life are formed
carl sagan chose aptly when he said that
we are all star stuff
it's important to remember that not only
is ordinary matter coming together and
clumping but that undiscovered substance
that we call dark matter is also
swimming through the cosmos
since we don't know what dark matter is
we can't speak of its creation and
evolution
if dark matter is made of a simple wimp
then perhaps made from
processes involving supersymmetry
it was probably formed in the desert
between 10 to the minus 32 seconds when
the grand unified force broke into the
electro weak and strong forces and 10 to
the minus 12 seconds when the electro
weak force split into the weak force and
electromagnetism
but all bets are off if the idea of
complex dark matter proves to be real
after all we don't know the physics that
will bind together dark matter
dark electromagnetism if it exists is
completely unknown
however we do know of one more
transition in the history of the
universe one that's continuing today
after the universe began and the big
bang flung the matter of the universe
across the cosmos the expansion
continued with gravity's inexorable tub
ever slowing the expansion
that is until a fateful day about 5
billion years ago it might have been a
tuesday cosmologically speaking just
shortly before our own sun was formed an
energy field of constant density was
beginning to become important
about nine billion years after the
universe began this dark energy became
the largest source of energy in the
cosmos
and as we've seen dark energy is a
repulsive form of gravity
the expansion of the universe was no
longer slowing it was accelerating
now it doesn't take much of a leap to
see the parallels between dark energy
and inflation
in both instances the expansion of the
universe accelerated
the two phenomena are different of
course one occurred in far less than the
blink of an eye while the other is far
slower inflation occurred in the
confines of virtually no space while the
effects of dark energy depend on very
large amounts of space
further it appears that dark energy has
always been part of the cosmos while the
energy of inflation may have come from a
one-time phase transition between the
grand unified force and the strong and
electroweak forces
so it's hard to generalize from one to
the other
going forward we can predict what we'll
see if dark energy remains a constant
energy field it will continue to
accelerate the expansion of the universe
until distant galaxies that are now
visible move so far away that the light
that is emitted from them never arrives
eventually the universe will look very
different with only a few nearby
galaxies visible in the remainder gone
forever
astronomers looking at the night sky
from the vicinity of earth would imagine
a very different cosmos than the one we
see now it is in the stories that i've
told you in this lecture that the need
for a theory of everything becomes the
most clear
for as long as there's been writing
mankind has wondered about such
questions as where we came from and
where we're going
and over the millennia many ideas have
been proposed however our understanding
has been greatly quantified over the
years especially over the last few
centuries and we now know a great deal
but we want to know more
and it will take a theory of everything
for us to be able to complete the
cosmological story of where we came from
in our next lecture i'll discuss
questions of what came before the big
bang and what exists outside our
universe
[Music]